so next game we're a little late
now I'm already 25 seconds away
okay
so again
yes the early so to two already prevents
bishop F5
first of all but it
makes it easier to move the black C5
up now five next time
because the queen on C2 in this one
isolani position
sometimes not so good stands
on the finish line it is usually
uncomfortable or sometimes gets
pregnant with it B4 and so on is bothered
opponent is by the way again an
American Elu
with a retin of two three 56
runners I find the three strange
since I am now  directly knight B4
so D4 is now actually the
logical move
to open it up, maybe hold
knight E4
and the position opens up massively
yes, well, I'm better developed so
I mean
jumps E4 is of course possible now,
you have to look at it knight
beats E4 bishop E4  Is it possible because there are
five checks, I can move B4 by
taking it if he then moves the king
I could take three anyway,
H7 also depends on checks but okay that
takes a lot of time so I could
then take E3 yes that was also possible
but in the end  The jumps are also
very, very decentralized here
so if I just
pull away bishops
let's say yes maybe even after
you six
yes six
so I think
exactly I thought E4 he has to
move but of course he is
already very tense here with the
figures of the  Jumps on A4, above
all, it's really ugly.
You should now take advantage of this as quickly as possible.
The three threatened to serve,
but if I now make the knight E5,
the three would win the pawn and
at the same time target the bishop here, the
seven
to ask the stranded knight about this
so now you have something better here
Lofer the seven maybe immediately
Knight C5 Rook C8
looks like gaining material where
you can also beat then bishop the
seven
yes they both both look very good
for Black
I do  It's not clear to me which
is better here,
so now it's time to do the math,
maybe they'll do the one,
okay, I'd like to lie
their way out of this by exchanging, but of course
the jump
still doesn't have a field, so if I
were to move the queen away now,
but then maybe the queen would have the one
Far away it's hanging, what does
it do because if, for example, I move Queen B8
so that the four jumps win the three
threaded figure
bishop c2d2 there is also a figure
here hanging two figures
bishop B5 he can play
and then I can
play B6 B6
B6 Queen B4  A5 wins a figure again,
okay,
I only have a minute 30 left, I have
my
figure,
okay,
time to catch up, he might
still have a bit of play with E45,
yes, that's also a bit
unpleasant, actually
try to exchange a little something on it,
so I'll do it  Yes, not yet to be taken because
on the tower of the 8 so that the 8
doesn't win with it, there is
still a speed here
so now it depends on that,
I meant that I have the queen away
and at least it can no
longer fish with checkmate in any way  so
you can clear it away
like a smooth smooth more piece for
a pawn okay
around the two
you can activate it a little bit here
so now the two don't do so
well to prevent or he just lets me get
into the position even more
so another pawn
nice that I somehow cover each other here
let's push the pawn
through
the next rook H4 checkmate or tom F1
checkmate
nice with 13 seconds we're
happy to take checkmate in check made yes that looked good
he had it  Simply
neglecting the development too much
somehow
this whole structure here with bishop
D3 is strange because now
black is better developed here I
already have high now and
I think the move is really
weak so
knight E4 would probably have to try to get
it  It's
better to replace it with it, so I think
it looked nice in black,
but
I can just see a
variant here. Knight here, knight beats
E44, the three
is interesting because he can't
take on C5 because of the queen, the two chess
king than he
could back then  be good for Black, he can
take seven, okay, but
then I was able to get E3 in there and
completely destroy the structure with the
king, which actually looked like a
reasonable game